هذه العباره تستخدم الان في لحظات سعاده
بانقاذ احد ناجين من تحت الانقاض او خيبه
امل باستخراج جثه هامده كلا الجسدين
يلتفان بالبطانيات فرق الانقاذ في سوريا
تعمل بكافه طاقتها الاستيعابيه لانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه ازاله الانقاض وتوثيق الضحايا
الا ان نقص المعدات الاكثر اساسيه يجعل
العمليات بدائيه لتكون البطانيات هي
النقالات الوحيده الموجوده في الميدان
وتكون بقايا الملابس الممزقه ضمادات لجراح
بعض الناجين
وضع يتفاقم ويتازم بمرور الوقت فالكارثه
لم تتوقف بتوقف الزلزال بل كل تاخيرا في
وصول المساعدات من المعدات الاساسيه
والطبيه يزيد عدد الضحايا لتكون مقابل كل
ساعه تاخير 50 حاله وفاه تقول تقديرات فرق
الانقاذ الاليات المتوفره بين يدي فرق
الدفاع المدني المؤديات هي صراحه غير
كافيه لحتى حتى ينجز العمل بشكل سريع وحتى
نسحب العالقين من تحت الانقاذ بشكل سريع
الكارثه الطبيعيه التي حلت بالشمال السوري
زادت موتا على الموت الذي يواجهه سكان
المنطقه كل يوم من اوضاع انسانيه صعبه
ثلاث سنين الحرب السوريه الطويله ونزوح
وفقر وحصار وحاجه ملحه
للمساعدات تضاعفت في ظل زلزال القرن
[موسيقى]
ولم تكن مناطق سيطره النظام في سوريا افضل
حالا ليعترف الاخير ويقر بان البلاد ليست
مهيئه لتبعات هذا النوع من الكوارث وتعاني
نقصا حادا في المعدات اللازمه لرفع
الانقاض والمعدات الطبيه ايضا وعمر
العربيه